let's discuss whether there is any link
between violence on the screen and real
violence with Ben Shapiro
editor-in-chief of The Daily wire and
retired Army lieutenant colonel
David Grossman who's authored books on
the psychology of violence Ben Shapiro I
know you're skeptical about a link from
video games millions and millions of
people play these video games I mean
girls aren't as into these video games
I'm sorry as boys are but but I think if
my son's had access to them I'm sure
that played them all the time because
something out the boys brain and these
games but why are you not worried about
it well I mean I'm not supremely worried
about it just because the consumption
these violent video games has been going
up continuously since the early 90s and
yet youth violence has been going down
since the early 90s the correlation
actually doesn't fit as far as
individual instances I mean you can find
patterns in in spy in very sporadic
instances among virtually all data sets
but there's some pretty mixed data about
this it's true that the American
Psychological Association recommends
that parents not allow their kids to
play these games I wouldn't let my kids
play these games because I think they're
immoral frankly but that should really
be up to the parents I'm not sure the
government should be in the business of
stepping in in 2011 Justice Scalia and a
majority decision 5-4 found that it was
actually unconstitutional for the state
of California to regulate the capacity
of parents to be able to get these video
games for their kids or even for kids to
get them themselves without parental
permission you saw that as a Content
violation under the First Amendment
let's talk more about this the the
assassinations that take place in the
games you know my book Laura
assassination generation we outlined the
dissenting opinions in that case there's
much more to this situation that we need
to understand you know where Clarence
Thomas and Stephen brer the most liberal
most conservative justices dissented
Stephen Breyer said they use these to
train military it's I'm not a I'm not a
medical expert but I know who is it it's
not the people the video game industry
put out they need to know more about
that case the data is so overwhelming
and when I was a kid nobody called their
seat belt we're all just fine not
everybody building buckled ID but all
the ones that died had their seats are
you saying a kids who have
predispositions to this yeah
that maybe maybe they have a trigger
inside of them they steep them to it a
great book inside the mind of a teen
killer though their new factor in every
single case that new factor that the
fact that violent crime is down is not -
in the law they using these an Army Army
Ranger training but they did do video
some simulation now we do do it with law
enforcement and military training we use
simulators you don't see the Ranger
school but you see it as an integral
part of our training to make killing a
conditioned response it's part of modern
training we've gotta do it healthy
people have to be trained to kill in the
video games through the same thing to
the kids and then but what I always
think about this is you know scientists
science or not for young children to
continually see images of heads
exploding chest opening up you talked
about the immorality of all this whether
whether its constitutional or not
constitutional maybe as a society we
have to talk about what numbing
ourselves to this very graphic violence
it's not it's like cartoon this looks
like a real person's head exploding and
it's over and over and over again and
you're doing it ten hours a day and
you're playing with people in other
countries that's where you're that's
where you're getting your stimulation
and that's boys need to be outside
playing they need to be doing physical
stuff instead they're sitting there on
these on these screens all day I just
don't see how I know that's good I fully
agree with with all of that I just think
there's a question of parental authority
and I think it's a question of how we
decided to choose to raise their kids
not necessarily question governmental
regulation and the problem I have with
the president getting involved is is
whether this is gonna be a cultural
issue or is this a regulatory issue is
this an issue where the president tries
to promulgate some sort of legislative
response or what we're supposed to think
that the government is going to step in
and fix all of this because again I'm
not sure that the statistics match up in
terms of just public policy but I think
we're all in agreement that we'd all
prefer that kids play less of this and
we have a pretty robust rating system on
video games as well I hope it gets more
robust and I hope more parents take
responsibility for the crap that kids
are putting in their system
you know the Adam Lanza it's such an
empty empty look in his face he
obviously had severe mental problems as
well as a particular kids from guns and
tobacco and alcohol and pornography sex
automobiles firearms and all those out
there is they wouldn't buckle a baby in
their car seats it wasn't the law
it's not get done until we take action
most major nations on the planet
regulate children's access to these
games we're about the only major nation
that doesn't do that well I'm glad I
don't like these games so it's great to
have both of you on